joining me now for reaction senator from
the great state of south carolina
chairman of the judiciary committee
senator lindsey graham welcome to you
senator how are you
you're doing great it's not as easy as
it looks is it you're doing really good
i'm doing great trey it's a good day for
the rule of law
yeah you know senator i was thinking on
the way over here
over the past four years there have been
more fbi employees indicted than there
have been trump family
members what does that say about what
this country's been through over the
last four years
well there's a couple of story lines
today an
fbi lawyer in charge of reviewing
warrants
is going to plead guilty to falsifying
documents to the fisa court
against a trump advisor and if you're
lucky you'll find this in the mainstream
media for 30 seconds
can you imagine if the shoe were on the
other foot
an fbi lawyer pled guilty today to
falsifying documents against hillary
clinton's
advisor it'd be front page news so
that's the world in which we live in
but i want to applaud uh mr horowitz the
inspector general without him we
wouldn't have known this
and what this lawyer did is a really big
deal
we have to trust the system there's got
to be a certain amount of trust
this is a lawyer a man of the law
a member of the bar who took it upon
himself to falsify a document to keep an
investigation going
that should have been stopped now the
media can't figure out why why they
hated trump's guts
so this is a big day for the rule of law
and
something tells me that mr kleinsmith
knows where the bodies are buried
and if i were in the fbi working on
crossfire hurricane
i'd be very worried about right now
speaking of working for the fbi and
being worried you were concerned that
the fbi maybe had misled the senate
intelligence committee can you update us
on that and what you have learned and
what you're working on
this is a big day uh for transparency in
the rule of law so
mr horowitz it's not in his report trey
but he found a briefing document uh and
uh dated sometime in february 2018
that was prepared by the fbi because the
senate intel committee used to
use to be on the house intel committee
had real concerns about the russian
sub-source
so they asked the fbi to come in and
brief them so i asked
director ray who did the briefing well
it's bill prestab
who's this guy he's one of the leaders
of crossfire hurricane
a year after the subsource told the fbi
uh in 2017 there's no there's zero
corroboration for the dossier
i wouldn't trust it with a you know
solid grain assault hearsay bar
talk they knew for over a year and now
you've got bill priestep
on february 15 2018 with four other
people from the fbi
briefing this senate intel committee
completely whitewashing
the truth about the reliability of the
dossier
now uh our directorate has been really
good
he's given me the information moore's
going to follow but what i'm going to do
with this
is turn it over to durham because i
think
the briefing in 2018 a year after the
sub-source told the fbi the dossier
was a bunch of garbage whitewashing that
report the senate intel committee
is potentially another crime so i'm
going to send all this to durham when i
get it
senator the american people are watching
democrats and mayors of of liberal and
progressive cities
complain about state local police
misconduct
where is the outrage among democrats
when you have policemen conduct
misconduct over an entity they actually
have power over control over which is
the fbi
why is there not more bipartisan outrage
over the last four years
to my judiciary committee democrats
this is about the rule of law many of
you been u.s attorneys
what we have here is an fbi lawyer
falsifying documents to the fisa court
to keep an investigation going that
should have stopped
falsifying documents to get a warrant
against an american citizen
part of a presidential campaign we now
have in 2018
a year after sub-source told the fbi
was a bunch of garbage the dossier an
effort by the fbi to lie to the congress
and the reason priestapp lied to the
congress
is if he told the congress the truth
about what the sub source told the fbi
he would expose the lie to the court so
mr horowitz deserves a lot of credit
here
where is this thing going the next thing
i'm going to do trey
is i'm going to call to the committee
and interview
the case agent and the intel analyst who
interviewed the russian sub source
in january and march of 2017
and they got memos showing that it was a
bunch of garbage
the guy denied the reliability did i say
it's bar talk it was here so
here's a zero corroboration and here's a
simple question
the most high profile case maybe ever in
the history of the fbi
the document needed to get a warrant
against carter page
completely fell apart in terms of
reliability
who did you tell what's the likelihood
that the people who interviewed the
russian sub-source did not tell mccabe
who's
writing hurt on the investigation
eventually comey
oh by the way our case fell apart that's
where i'm headed
and if they knew about this interview if
they got a warrant in april and june
months after the interview they should
go to jail
senator let me ask you quickly we got
about 20 seconds what is the future if
any of fisa
it's hanging in a balance because people
abuse power
and god knows we need it because the
terrorists are coming after us and we've
got to rehabilitate the system
and the only way people are going to
trust the fbi and fisa in the future
is for people who lied cheated and
manipulated to be fired and go to jail
stay tuned